the islamist militia boko haram has
claimed responsibility for the
kidnapping of over 300 schoolchildren in
northern nigeria
in a voice recording sent to a nigerian
newspaper
the head of the group abu bakr
justified the abduction of the schoolboy
saying that boko haram
rejected western education the recording
could not be independently verified
gunmen attacked a secondary school in
the city of kankara
on friday night many of the 600 boys
present at the school were able to
escape local authorities say that they
have entered negotiations with the
let's kidnappers in flourish tokura who
joins us now from lagos
do we have any idea of how the boys are
doing and whether there is any chance
that they will be released
well we don't have any information about
how the boys are doing
however what we do know about the boys
is that
um the ones that were able to escape
some of them were able to run into the
bushes
and um they were able to find a few of
them
but the ones that have been kidnapped we
don't have any information about them
what we what we also know is that
there's a possibility that it wasn't
boko haram who kidnapped these boys
locals in the community of kankara
actually believed that
this kidnap was done by bandits in the
area
but um if i understand correctly boko
haram has claimed responsibility so i
mean what do we what more do we know
about that
yes boko haram has claimed
responsibility but when you go to
kankara
in casino state a lot of people believe
there that the kidnapping was done by
the bandits now the reason why they
believe it was done by the bandits and
not boko haram
is because bandits have been operating
in that area according to them for
around 10 years
and they've tried to attack the school
about three times
unsuccessfully and after this kidnapped
was carried out
they asked for ransom which is very
unlike boko haram
now people are saying that boko haram is
only claiming responsibility
because they are seeking global
recognition
they want to claim this attack whereas
it wasn't really them that performed it
but nobody really knows
who is behind them it is true that boko
haram is claiming responsibility
president buhari meantime repeatedly
promising to tackle islamist terrorism
what's gone wrong
i wish i could answer that question what
has gone wrong
he promised nigeria that he was going to
fix islamic
islamic terrorism since 2015
this is year five and we are yet to see
any improvement
in fact things have been getting worse
progressively
just about three weeks ago there was an
attack where hundred farmers were killed
by boko haram in the southeast of
nigeria
now this attack in the southwest and
this would be the very first of its kind
in southwest nigeria i mean in this
magnitude
we have hundreds of people being
kidnapped and it's even in the
in the home state of president buhari
himself he's from kastina state
so i think this is a big blow and a
message to nigerians
that the words of president buhari don't
really match the news don't really match
what we are seeing on the ground
if incidents like this keep happening
over and over again
and yet the president is coming out to
tell people that boko haram has been
technically defeated
or has been uh has been ended but we are
still seeing attacks and what is really
happening
so i think this is a question for
president buhari and his team to answer
flores tokura in lagos nigeria thank you